jetzt geht es um die beratung des
antrages der fraktionen der afg
verstärktes vorgehen gegen
linksextremismus zum schutz der
demokratie so lautet der die fdp
fraktion fordert dass zum schutz der
demokratie verstärkt gegen
linksextremismus vorgegangen werden soll
es soll mehr personal und mehr mittel
eingesetzt werden um gegen gewaltbereite
linksextremistische bündnisse vereine
und organisationen vorzugehen
vereinsverbote und verbote von internet
plattformen sollen geprüft und
gegebenenfalls schnell umgesetzt werden
konkret geht es der fdp unter anderem um
nachfolge plattformen der verbotenen
plattform links unten oder indymedia org
sowie um organisationen wie die
interventionistische linke der nächste
und erster redner in dieser debatte ist
martin hess für die afd
er ist mitglied im innenausschuss auf
den eigentlichen antrag ein gedi afd hat
schon immer und jegliche form von
extremismus egal ob links rechts oder
islamismus scharf verurteilt
wir müssen aber konstatieren dass gegen
rechtsextremismus in geeigneter weise
vorgegangen wird und auch den
islamistischen extremismus mit einer
gewissen entschlossenheit begegnet wird
wenn hier natürlich auch noch
entsprechende optimierungsbedarf besteht
einzig der linksextremismus nur vom
staat kaum bekämpft und deshalb ist
dieser antrag erforderlich den
linksextremismus und daran kann und darf
kein zweifel bestehen ist eine massive
bedrohung für unsere demokratie für
unsere gesellschaft und unsere
sicherheitsorgane die gewalttaten mit
linksextremistischem hintergrund haben
2017 um 37,2 prozent zugenommen sie
richteten sich zu 69 prozent gegen
polizei und sicherheitsbehörden
wir alle erinnern uns noch an die
bürgerkriegsähnlichen szenen beim
g20-gipfel in hamburg linksextremisten
zogen marodieren durch die straßen in
blinder zerstörungswut setzen sie
fahrzeuge und barrikaden in brand
zerschlugen fensterscheiben ein
plünderten hemmungslos geschäfte und
griffen mit pflastersteinen und mit
präzisionsschleudern abgeschossene
stahlkugeln auf die sicherheitskräfte in
ihrer menschenverachtung gegen die links
extremisten so weit dass die
polizeikräfte mit voller absicht in
hinterhalte locken um sie dort mit
gehwegplatten und molotow-cocktails
anzugreifen
nur durch den einsatz von spezialkräften
und die verlegung aller bundesweit
verfügbaren polizeikräfte nach hamburg
konnte die lage bewältigt werden 231
polizeibeamte wurden damals verletzt
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren es
wird zeit dass wir die dinge wieder beim
namen nennen als polizist und als
politiker sage ich ihnen in aller
deutlichkeit das ist kein
linksextremismus mehr
das ist linksterrorismus
und
wer mit steinen zwei eisenstangen gegen
polizei wir haben die vorgeht liebe
links grün roten kollegen und auch an
die teile medien gerichtet das ist kein
aktivist das ist und bleibt ein
gewaltverbrechen dass sich linke grüne
spd angesichts solcher fakten nach wie
vor weigerung die erschreckende
dimension linke gewalt überhaupt zur
kenntnis zu nehmen
ja sie sogar verharmlosen relativieren
und leugnen und dass die regierung immer
noch außer stande ist effektive
maßnahmen gegen link gegen die
linksterrorismus zu ergreifen das ist
und man muss es so deutlich sagen eine
bankrotterklärung dieses
parlamentspräsidentin power frau
ministerin bali und die kolleginnen und
kollegen hügel göring eckardt hofreiter
letztem eric singer kipping haben mit
der interventionistischen linken
zusammen einen aufruf unterzeichnet der
sich gegen unsere demokratisch gewählte
partei richtet dabei hat die
interventionistische linke für ist sie
für die gewaltausbrüche beim g20 gipfel
mit verantwortlichen laut
bundesregierung spielt sie auch eine
maßgebliche rolle bei den
ausschreibungen und im hambacher forst
wo polizeibeamte massiv mit steinen
flaschen und fäkalien angegriffen wurden
nur zur erinnerung die lage warburg so
angst dass ich ein kollege nur mit einem
beinschuss retten konnte die
interventionistische linke ist daher
unbestreitbar eine verfassungsfeindliche
organisation und mit einer
verfassungsfeindlichen organisationen da
kooperiert man nicht die verbietet man
und zwar sofort
die unfähigkeit der bundesregierung bei
der bekämpfung des linksextremismus
führt zu immer häufigeren und zu immer
schwereren angriffen auf die organe
unseres staates dass ich nenne hier nur
exemplarisch ein paar beispiele im april
20 18 greifen linksterroristen vor dem
besetzten haus in riga straße wiederholt
polizeiwagen mit steinen an auf in die
medien auf indymedia rufen sie zu
weiteren steinwürfen auf und sie
schreiben dort ich zitiere die durch die
stadt streifen schweine sind wir uns
nichts weiter als verachtenswerte
subjekte denen wir ihre streifenfahrt
zur gefahr werden lassen zitat ende
im august 20 18 stimmen linksterroristen
die berliner senats justizverwaltung und
bedrohen dort einen referatsleiter im
dezember 20 18 von linksterroristen
einen brandanschlag auf dem fünfte
strafsenat des bgh in leipzig und die
bundesregierung ist nicht in der lage
dies und massiven linksextremistischen
gefahr für unsere demokratie und unsere
gesellschaft effektive maßnahmen
entgegen zu setzen sie schafft es nicht
einmal die internetplattform dauerhaft
abzuschalten
auf der die terroristen ihre
bekennerschreiben veröffentlichen durch
einen simplen wechsel der web domain
umgehen diese linksextremisten das boot
des innenministers und verbreiten weiter
ihre staatsfeindliche und
menschenverachtende propaganda zuletzt
sogar ein sabotage handbuch in dem
anleitungen zur zerstörung von eigentum
und zur zerstörung der existenz von
fdp-mitgliedern abgegeben werden
bis hin und das muss man sich mal
vorstellen zum mörderischen abwurf
schwerer steine von autobahnbrücken
damit meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren muss endlich schluss sein
wir müssen diese staats und menschen
vereine mit aller konsequenz und mit
allerhand bekämpfen leben nicht wie
einige politiker aus dem linken spektrum
dieser linksextremen gewalt auch noch
mit aggressiver rhetorik befeuerung spd
vize ralf stegner machten 516 auf
twitter fakt bleibt man muss positionen
und personal der rechtspopulisten
attackieren und gewitzte wir sagte vor
der bundestagswahl in einer woche könnte
es sein dass oftmals wie der nazis in
den bundestag einziehen ist das kein an
was zu sagen wir wollen alles dafür tun
dass diese brut in diesem land nichts zu
sagen hat und ich möchte daran erinnern
als bundestagspräsident schäuble am
elfter september letzten jahres dazu
aufruft aufrief linksextreme gewalt
ebenso abzulehnen wie
rechtsextremistische da verweigerten sie
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
von linken spd und grünen diesem
demokratischen minimalkonsens den
applaus und das zeigt doch ganz
eindeutig wo die wahren demokratie
feinde diesem parlament sitzen nämlich
links die büroleiterin von andrea nahles
angela marquardt schrieb am 17 september
18 m spd organ vorwärts im kampf gegen
rechts braucht die spd auch die antifa
in ihrem kampf gegen rechts und
wohlgemerkt gegen rechts nicht gegen
rechtsextremismus sondern gegen rechts
eine völlig legitime demokratische
strömung haben sie keinerlei skrupel mit
gruppierung zu kooperieren die vom
verfassungsschutz den gewaltorientierten
linksextremismus zugeordnet werden
und das zeigt uns doch ganz eindeutig
dass es ihnen gar nicht um den schutz
unserer demokratie geht sondern nur
darum den primitiven erhalt ihrer macht
und jeder finanziellen mittel meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren die seit
ihrer verbalen angriffe auf unsere
partei geht auf einen
sprengstoffanschlag gegen eine fd
bürgerbüro in döbeln fordert indes hat
keine verletzten oder sogar toten weil
keine menschen waren und vor wenigen
tagen wurden unsere abgeordnete frank
marx nichts mit einem angriff schwer am
kopf verletzt und von dieser stelle aus
dem oberfranken ich hoffe ich mache das
nicht nur im namen meiner fraktion
wünschen gute besserung und schnelle
genesung
dabei ist der kollege mark nichts
beiläufigkeit einzelfall
unsere fraktionsvorsitzenden rheinland
pfalz und jungen alle im august 2016
durch schläge und tritte ins gesicht
einen jochbeinbruch der abgeordnete kai
gutzeit wurde beim bundesparteitag in
hannover attackiert und schwer an der
hand verletzt unsere häuser werden
beschädigt unsere autos verbrannt unsere
büros demoliert damit soll der
demokratischen diskurs in diesem land
gegen werden und damit wird die
meinungsfreiheit immerhin einer der
zentralen grundpfeiler unserer
demokratie massiv angegriffen
jeder überzeugte und aufrechter demokrat
steht daher in der pflicht sich diesen
linksextremistischen angriffen
entschlossen entgegen zu stellen
beweisen sie dass sie es ernst meinen
mit der wehrhaften demokratie zeigen sie
dass sie auch für die freiheit vor dass
sie sich auch für die freiheit von
meinungen einsetzen die ihre eigenen
widersprechen und vielleicht sogar auch
schwer erträglich sein mögen aber genau
das zeichnet eben auch eine wahren
demokraten aus wenn sie weiterhin
zulassen dass linksextremisten und
linksterroristen unsere demokratie und
unsere gesellschaft gefährden
dann geht jeder weitere anschlag jeder
weitere verletzung was gott verhüten
möge jeder künftige tote auf ihr konto
das müssen wir verhindern die zeit des
redens ist definitiv vorbei jetzt muss
endlich gehandelt werden ich appelliere
daher an sie unserem antrag zuzustimmen
martinez war das von der afg vorgehen
gegen linksextremismus ist der
tagesordnungspunkte und der nächste
redner der jetzt hier dazu spricht kommt
von der cdu/csu jetzt milde ergebnis der
namentlichen abstimmung über den
gesetzentwurf der bundesregierung mit
wenn du auf eins gesetzte einstufen
georgiens der demokratischen
volksrepublik gehen das königreich
marokko und der tunesischen republik als
sie ihre herkunftsstaaten drucksache 19
53 14 und 19 65 38 46 stimmen wurden
abgegeben mit ja haben gestimmt 5 109
mit nein namen und stehe mit 138 4
enthaltungen der gesetzentwurf ist damit
angenommen
über den
entschließungsantrag der abgeordnete
linda teuteberg stefan tomik regio ag
liedes und weitere abgeordnete der
fraktion der fdp zur dritten beratung
des gesetzentwurfs der bundesregierung
den titel ist nicht nur mal vor die
drucksachen nummer auch nicht haben die
schriftführer folgendes ergebnisse
ermitteln schriftführerin und
schriftführung ich hab mir auch noch mal
zu hause arbeit aber wir geben nicht
eben 645 mit jahr haben sich 750 mit
nein haben bestimmt 495
entschließungsantrag
ich habe ich abgelehnt und damit sie ja
aber der gesetzentwurf meine damen und
herren der bundesregierung der ist halt
angenommen worden mit 509 stimmen von
641 das parlament hat übrigens 709
abgeordnete relativ viele abgeordnete
nicht da
138 waren dagegen nun kommt das gesetz
in den bundesrat und über die
problematik hatte ich sie ja vorhin
schon auf dem laufenden halten
das dürfte schwierig und eng werden
mathias middelberg der innenpolitische
sprecher der cdu csu hat jetzt das wort
extreme gewalt und die links politisch
motivierte kriminalität in deutschland
machen uns auch sorgen die zahlen 2017
im verhältnis zu 2016 zeigen dass das
gesamt straftat aufkommen politisch
motivierter kriminalität links um 3,9
prozent gewachsen ist und auch bei den
politisch motivierten gewalttaten also
tötungs und körperverletzungsdelikten
haben wir einen anstieg von 15,6 prozent
zu verzeichnen
ereignisse wie g20 sind angesprochen
worden
es gibt also einen anstieg auch
linksextremistischer gewalt dem müssen
wir uns stellen aber dem stellen wir uns
auch sehr konsequent
wir handeln aber nicht nur nach links
sondern gegen alle formen des
extremismus ganz gleich ob der von links
rechts oder religiös motiviert ist wir
verurteilen alle formen des extremismus
gleichermaßen und gegen gegen alle diese
formen schon seit 2012 gibt es das
gemeinsame extremismus und terrorismus
abwehrzentrum die
kommunikationsplattform für polizei
nachrichtendienst auf bundes und auf
länderebene
wir steigern den personalbestand beim
bundeskriminalamt das betrifft auch den
personalausweis im bereich der
bekämpfung der pmk links um 54 stellen
ganz konkret und wir haben gehandelt mit
dem verbot der internetplattform links
unten in die media wir haben bisher noch
keine veritablen erkenntnisse dafür dass
die betreiber der neuen plattform die
ähnliche namen führen identisch sind mit
der verbotenen plattform und dass dieses
vereins verbot umgangen wird
aber wir beobachten die szene weiter
sehr aufmerksam
im übrigen ist die bundeszentrale für
politische bildung tätig im vorfeld und
das alles ist auch richtig so
ich will aber klarstellen es gibt eben
auch extremismus nicht nur von links
sondern genauso von politisch rechts
oder mit religiös ideologisch
motivierten hintergrund die straftaten
von der rechten seite sind zuletzt um 13
prozent zurückgegangen sie sind aber was
ihre zahl insgesamt angeht höher als die
von linksextremistischer seite die
straftaten mit dem religiös wohl eher
ideologisch im hintergrund sind um fast
53 prozent ist die wir sind insgesamt
noch kleiner von der zahl her aber die
steigerung
uns eben besondere sorgen dies ist alles
kein schöner befund jede extremistische
straftat ist eine zuviel und kein
extremismus um das klar und deutlich zu
sagen ist irgendwie besser oder
schlechter als ein anderer
und man muss auch für keine form von
extremismus irgendwie verständnis haben
wir legen alles gleichermaßen und
politische straftaten sind immer eine
ganz schwierige sache
weil die täter sich durch ihre ideologie
und manchmal vorgeschobene ideologie
irgendwie besonderer weise
gerechtfertigt fühlen und weil getroffen
werden im unterschied zur
alltagskriminalität nicht nur die
jeweiligen opfer sondern betroffen
werden häufig ganze gruppen von personen
in der gesellschaft die entweder
aufgrund ihrer volkszugehörigkeit
ethnischer herkunft religion sexuelle
orientierung sich durch solche
straftaten letzten endes bedroht fühlen
und auch angst entwickeln deswegen
gefährden solche politisch motivierten
straftaten unsere freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung insgesamt und
deswegen stellen wir uns diesen
straftaten mit besonderer härte und mit
besonderer konsequenz und das zeigt dass
wir am ende nicht differenzieren dürfen
es war richtig dass wir hier über
chemnitz und die straftaten die es dort
gegeben hat die ausfälle nicht nur die
hitler grüße andere dinge auch egal ob
das jetzt hetze oder hetze achten waren
spielt keine rolle dass wir über diese
dinge klar und deutlich hier im haus
gesprochen haben die durchsetzung des
rechts und das gewaltmonopol dieses
staates sind nicht relativiert ganz
gleich in welcher richtung ob von links
oder rechts und ich habe mich darüber
gefreut sage ich ihnen auch deutlich
dass die leute die da den hitlergruß
gezeigt haben zwei wochen später dort
vor dem richtertisch dann das ist
richtig so dass unsere
statt schnell reagiert aber ich sage
auch ganz klar in alle richtungen dieses
hauses es darf überhaupt keine rolle
spielen ob da steine oder flaschen oder
sonstwie gewalt angewandt wird gegen
einen flüchtling gegen einen
polizeibeamten wie bei g20 oder gegen
irgendwelche politiker egal ob von links
oder von rechts oder von der afg oder
von sonst wem das alles sind miese und
fiese straftaten die dringend und hart
verfolgt gehören
es gab keine unterschiede geben und wir
müssen so wie wir über chemnitz klar
gesprochen haben auch genauso über g20
sprechen und über die taten im hambacher
forst dietz wilde schüsse auf polizei
und das werfen von molotow-cocktails
brandstiftungen fäkalien wurf auf
polizisten sind tatsächlich keine
aktivitäten von aktivisten sondern es
sind straftaten gibt verfolgt gehört und
deswegen gehen wir weiter mit dem
konsequenten kurs gegen rechts wie links
es macht übrigens zahlenmäßig gar keinen
unterschied der verfassungsschutzbericht
sagt uns es gibt 24 1000 rechtsextreme
in deutschland es gibt 28.000
linksextreme bei den rechtsextremen gibt
es einen etwas höheren anteil
gewaltorientierten bei den linksextremen
ist etwas geringer
im grunde macht es wenig unterschied wir
werden gegen beide gruppierungen und
auch gegen die religiös motivierten
weiter konsequent vorgehen mit der
stärkung unseres rechtsstaats mit einer
wehrhaften demokratie und mit dem pakt
für den rechtsstaat den wir hier immer
wieder regelmäßig im haus beraten in
seinen einzelnen schritten diesen kurs
gegen links gegen rechts gegen religiös
motiviert werden wir konsequent
fortsetzen
verzichtbar mathias middelberg war das
der innenpolitische sprecher der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion nächste
redner kommt jetzt von der fdp benjamin
strasser sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir haben zweifelsohne ein problem mit
linksextremismus in deutschland und was
mich besonders besorgt wir haben es laut
verfassungsschutzbericht mit einer
steigenden anzahl gewaltbereiter
linksextremisten zu tun
das kann jeden demokraten und jede
demokraten in diesem land nicht kalt
lassen war vor allem weil es ein
jahrelanger trend ist die mir beobachtet
haben wir als freie demokraten haben
damals regiert zu unserer reagiert zu
unserer schwarz gelben regierungszeit
und haben die mittel die maßnahmen im
kampf gegen linksextremismus
entsprechend erhöht umso bedauerlicher
ist es herr kollege mittelberg dass es
ihre fraktionen die union gemeinsam mit
der spd war die ab dem jahr 2013 die
mittel wieder zurückgefahren hat im
kampf gegen linksextremismus das waren
verlorene jahre
im kampf in diesem bereich liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir können auch
nicht davor die augen zu schließen wenn
linksextreme in diesem land zunehmend
gewalt nicht nur gegen sachen sondern
auch gegen menschen und insbesondere
gegen die polizei und einsatzkräfte in
unserem land verüben
sie sind es nämlich die die knochen
hinhalten für unsere offene gesellschaft
sie sind es die dafür sorgen dass in
deutschland nicht das gesetz der straße
sondern das gesetz des staates zur
anwendung kommt deswegen haben diese
menschen respekt und auf unseren schutz
verdient was wir aber leider erleben und
das eigentlich besonders ist dass es
hier vertreterinnen und vertreter
demokratische parteien in unserem land
gibt die linksextreme gewalt bewusst
oder unbewusst relativieren oder gar
verharmlosen
wenn der spd fraktionsvorsitzende im
landtag von schleswig holstein ralf
stegner nach dem g20 randalen in haben
und ernsthaft davon spricht ich zitiere
ideologisch gesehen ist die
verherrlichung von gewalt eher rechte
gesinnung schwarze block und hooligans
sind kriminelle keine linken zitat ende
dann verharmlost das linksextreme gewalt
in unserem land wenn polizistinnen und
polizisten im hambacher forst von
autonomen mit steinen molotow cocktails
und fäkalien beworfen werden dann ist
das kein kreativer protest sondern dann
ist das linksextreme gewalt in unserem
land und ich erwarte gerade von
demokratinnen und demokraten dass sie
nicht nur schweigen dass sie nicht nur
floskelhaft das bedauern sondern lassen
entschieden widersprechen auch gerade
von den linken demokratischen parteien
in unserem land denn eins ist doch klar
und das haben wir vor allem überlebt
erlebt verharmlosung und relativierung
stützt nur einer partei in diesem hohen
haus und diese am rechten rand
womit wir auch bei der afg werden das
was sie heute ja abgezogen haben das was
sie abgezogen haben das ist doch sehr
bemerkenswert ihr vermeintlicher kampf
gegen den linksextremismus dient dem
zweck und im ziel eigentlich nur dazu
ihre eigenen probleme mit rechtsextremen
in ihrer partei mit dem braunen flecken
in deutschland zu kaschieren und die
scheinwerfer entsprechend auf den
linksextremismus zu werfen
sie stellen einen wohlfeilen antrag
gegen linksextremismus in schaufenster
und im neckar die junge alternative
dekoriert den laden bei ihnen so
brauchen das jetzt der verfassungsschutz
entsprechend tätig werden muss aber aber
die spitze der scheinheiligkeit sind die
inhaltlichen forderungen in ihrem antrag
am letzten montag durften wir erleben
dass sie wahrheitswidrig behaupten die
anderen demokratischen parteien hätten
einfluss auf die entscheidung über die
beobachtung des verfassungsschutzes
genommen
verweile behauptet es sogar maße sein
und deswegen abgelöst werden drei tage
später stellen sie einen antrag in dem
sie die bundesregierung auffordern ein
vereinsverbot zu erlassen und genau
diesen politischen einfluss über den
deutschen bundestag auf die entscheidung
der bundesregierung neben wollen nur
weil es ihnen entsprechend passt was
gilt denn jetzt frau seidel ist es nur
wenn es bei ihm politisch opportun ist
dass man einschreiten soll oder sein
unsere sicherheitsbehörden nicht nach
recht und gesetz entscheiden und ich
habe das vertrauen in unsere
sicherheitsbehörden darf sie genau das
tun
im endeffekt und ich komme zum schluss
präsident der kampf gegen extremismus
wird nicht nur von sicherheitsbehörden
geführt sondern er wird von allen
demokratinnen und demokraten in diesem
land geführt und das liegt es auch an
uns parlamentariern entsprechend zu
handeln
populismus und extremismus leben vom
problem
es liegt an uns diese probleme zu lösen
und diesen leuten hier im parlament
nährboden zu entziehen
viel hat sich ein dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit benjamin strasser von fdp
war das mit einem engagierten vortrag
nächster redner in der debatte ist olic
von der spd
vielen dank herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen etwas
irritierend ist es schon dass die ofd
gerade in dieser woche einen antrag in
den deutschen bundestag einbringt indem
sie vorgibt die demokratie schützen zu
wollen
warum das nicht nur vom zeitpunkt her
schräg ist sondern warum der antrag zum
schutz der demokratie genauso ungeeignet
ist wie die ganze partei oder fraktion
zum schutz der demokratie wohl
ungeeignet ist will ich ihnen aber gerne
kurz darstellen
ich sage ihnen denen den schutz unserer
demokratie zu überlassen die dieses land
so wie es ist die das friedliche
zusammenleben in unserem land ablehnen
das ist so wie wenn man dann im
einbrecher einen schlüssel die schlüssel
zu seiner wohnung überlassen wird
und ich sage ihnen auch sie können uns
einer partei wie von kommunisten genauso
verfolgt wurde wie von rechtsextremisten
ganz bestimmt nichts gegen rechts gegen
extremismus prävention erzählen sehr
geehrte damen und herren von der afg und
ein das will ich auch mal klarstellen
danach sie gerne zu heerstraße es war
diese koalition und es waren spd
familienministerin die mittel im kampf
gegen politischen extremismus sei 2013
jahr für jahr aufgestockt haben die
mittel im kampf gegen den politischen
extremismus sind heute ist so hoch wie
es in der geschichte des landes es noch
nie waren merck sich das vielleicht
haben sie sich in der vorbereitung auf
ihre rede auch verlesen
natürlich und das ist ja völlig
unstrittig ist jede form des extremismus
zu fett zu verurteilen aber ich sage es
auch schon seit vielen jahren und ich
sage es ihnen auch heute gerne nochmal
ein vergleich von linksextremismus und
rechtsextremismus verbietet sich gerade
in unserem land es gibt in deutschland
drastisch viel mehr
es gibt in deutschland drastisch viel
mehr gewollt orientiert die
rechtsextreme aus linksextreme wir
hatten
[Applaus]
wir hatten im jahr 2017 trotz der hohen
zahlen durch den g 20 gipfel in hamburg
dreimal mehr straftaten die politische
rechtsextrem rechtsextrem motivierte
wurden als das von links der fall war
und natürlich ist jeder tote einer
zuviel natürlich ist jede straftat eine
zu viel aber ich sage es ihnen gerne mal
in zahlen seit 1990 hat der
linksextremismus tragischerweise vier
menschenleben gekostet seit 1990 im
gleichen zeitraum hat der
rechtsextremismus 194 menschenleben
gekostet sehr geehrte damen und herren
das ist ein punkt der hier erwähnung
finden sollte und wenn wir über zahlen
reden und die entwicklung von zahlen
dann wird das 2016 sogar noch deutlicher
wo die probleme mit dem politischen
extremismus in unserem land liegen 2016
hatten wir sogar viermal so viele
straftaten die mit rechtsextremistischen
hintergrund begangen wurden als wir
straftaten hatten die linksextremistisch
motiviert wurden vor allem aber ist hier
vergleicht deshalb brandgefährlich weil
er schwerste verbrechen relativiert die
rechtsextreme in diesem land verübt
haben stichwort nationalsozialistische
untergrund oder ich denke ganz aktuell
an die ns opfer anwältin seema basis die
drohbriefe von einem sogenannten nsu 2.0
erhalten hat in den offenbar sogar
polizeibeamte verstrickt sind das sind
die probleme mit denen wir uns beim
politischen extremismus zu aller erst
befassen müssen
um das noch mal zu sagen die wahre
gefahr in diesem land kommt immer noch
von rechts deshalb auch eben
linksextremismus mit rechtsextremismus
niemals auf eine stufe gestellt werden
und es und es ist schon immer
schrecklich und auch am heutigen tage
schändlich den versuch zu unternehmen
den scheinwerfer von rechts nach links
zu drehen weil es so rechts die
dunkelheit entsteht die wohl den begriff
dunkel deutschland vor ein paar jahren
in deutschland geprägt hat wir werden
auch weiterhin unser augenmerk auf den
rechtsextremismus richten auch wenn es
sie womöglich schmerzt und um es ganz
deutlich zu sagen nichts um es ganz
deutlich zu sagen
nichts rechtfertigt gewalt gegen
politiker ich wünsche ihren kollegen auf
baldige genesung und verurteile diesen
angriff
aber wie verzweifelt müssen sie denn
sein dass die angriffe aus schmitten
müssen angriffe auf kollegen ihrer
fraktion von wegen mit kantholz
geschlagen und von wegen am boden noch
nachgetreten wir haben das video doch
alle gesehen sie haben bewusst gelogen
weil sie als opfer linker gewalt
dastehen wollten das ist doch der
antrieb der dahinter steckt die märtyrer
krone verdienen sie kam es bestimmt
lichtraum wurde ist einfach nur
schändlich aber ich kann sie denn durch
beruhigen bleiben sie ruhig sehr geehrte
damen und herren von aufträgen bleiben
ich kann sie beruhigen auch den
linksextremismus haben unsere
sicherheitsbehörden natürlich auch dem
schirm
ich erinnere an das rigorose vorgehen
gegen die randalierer auf einem
g20-gipfel in hamburg und die hohen
strafen der gerichte die dem folgten was
sie mit verstärkten vorgehen konkret
meinen lassen sie ja irgendwo auch im
ungewissen
sie sind ja gerade darauf eingegangen er
ist hoffentlich meinen ziemlich zu etwas
mit den einsatz vom november 2008 in
berlin in der rigaer straße wo die
polizei nach vier tatverdächtigen mit
560 mann mit einem hubschrauber und
spezialkräften
gesucht hat wenn sie das damit meiner
mit entschlossenen handeln dann sollten
sie dringend auch noch mal in sich gehen
aber darum geht es immer noch gar nicht
es geht ihnen nicht darum gegen die
demokratie feinde vorzugehen und unsere
demokratie schützen weil sie unser land
so wie es ist das haben sie zuletzt erst
auf ihrem europa parteitag wieder
deutlich gemacht einfach ablehnen weil
sich selbst die feinde der demokratie
sind oliven menschen gar nicht es würde
gern eine zwischenfrage stellen
ich sage darf das noch mal es gibt in
ihrer fraktion nur einen bei dem ich
eine zwischenfrage zulasse sie sind
nicht herr hess ich lasse die frage
nicht zur präsidentin
ich komme zum schluss herr präsident ich
komme zum schluss ich habe verständnis
dafür dass sie derzeit sehr nervös sind
das hat man auch im innenausschuss diese
woche wieder gesehen weil sie das
bundesamt für verfassungsschutz ionen
aus polizei ein stoff auf über bleiben
sie durch auch über 440 seiten hat das
bav mit den landes
verfassungsschutzämter material
zusammengetragen die
verfassungsfeindliche tendenzen gelegen
wir haben sie jetzt schwarz auf weiß
dass sie die feinde der demokratie sind
seien sie sich sicher in der nächsten
zeit punkt ist bei ihnen auf jedes wort
an dass sie sagen oder schreiben wir
sind wachsam sein sie sich dessen gefahr
und wir sind mehr vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
olic war das von der spd jetzt
verteidigt das vor den kollegen andere
haben die linie
und das war ja zu erwarten andrian mit
einer persönlichen erklärung an realen
von der linken natürlich jetzt der
normale redner sorry ich hatte jetzt
erwartet das heißt das wort man mal
früher da habe ich mich vertan in
schuldig tendenzen inzwischen selbst vom
nun wahrlich nicht links orientierten
bundesamt für verfassungsschutz als
prüfer eingestuft wird
die afg verfolgt mit ihrem antrag ganz
erkennbar zwei ziele zum einen will sie
von ihren eigenen rechts extremistischen
strömungen und führungspersonen ablenken
und zum anderen will sich jene
diskreditieren und von staatlicher
förderung abschneiden die sich gegen
rassismus ausländerfeindlichkeit und
nationalismus mit friedlichen mitteln
zur wehr setzen
das werden wir ihnen nicht durchgehen
lassen die übergroße mehrheit der
menschen in diesem land steht für
toleranz weltoffenheit und ein
friedfertiges europa für alle und das
ist auch gut so für meine fraktion würde
ich ja noch mal ganz eindeutig erklären
die linke ist gegen jede form von gewalt
egal von wem sie ausgeht
und egal gegen wen sie gerichtet ist
gewalt gewalt ist kein mittel der
politischen auseinandersetzungen darf es
auch nie werden
gleichwohl inszeniert sich die afg gern
als opfer linker gewalt und das kommt
nicht von ungefähr denn dieser
opfermythos ist geradezu sinnstiftend
für diese partei er ist von zentraler
bedeutung für ihr selbstverständnis und
insbesondere für ihre selbstdarstellung
meine damen und herren reden wir noch
einmal über das verhältnis der afg zum
extremismus am montag dieser woche
griffen mitglieder der sogenannten
identitäten bewegung die der
fdp-bundestagsabgeordnete bis bonn gern
als vorfeldorganisation der afg
bezeichnet in einer bundesweit
konzertierten aktion zahlreiche medien
und parteibüros in ganz deutschland an
eine mitarbeiterin der tageszeitung taz
wurde von rechtsextremisten bedrängten
verletzt
der staatsschutz ermittelt wegen
hausfriedensbruch und gefährlicher
körperverletzung
meine damen und herren diese angriffe
auf journalisten und zeitungsredaktionen
ist absolut inakzeptabel
so etwas darf es nicht geben
und ich füge hinzu ich habe von der afg
dazu kein einziges wort der kritik
gehört und mit ihren teils auf dem
rassistischen äußerungen mit
nationalistischen und geschichts
relativierenden aussagen ihrer
mitglieder und funktionäre mit immer
neuen grenzüberschreitungen versuchen
sie die grenzen dessen was in diesem
land gesagt und getan werden darf stück
für stück nach rechts zu verschieben und
hier füge ich hinzu
vor allem auch die unionsfraktion darf
sich nicht dazu verleiten lassen diesem
wettbewerb mitzumachen sie kann und wird
ihn nicht gewinnen
die afg saß gegen minderheiten sie hetzt
gegen anders aussehende und anders
liebende und das ist übrigens ein grund
warum menschen vor parteitagen der afg
demonstrieren wie am letzten samstag
trotz teils heftigem regen fast 1500 in
riesa
auch dort geht auch dort wurden linke
krawalle von ihnen geradezu herbei
geredet es gab ein riesiges
polizeiaufgebot es wurde
innerstädtischen händlern von
offizieller seite sogar geraten ihre
läden zu schließen die demo ging
letztlich mitten durch die fußgängerzone
eine einkaufsstraße wo die meisten
geschäfte zum glück geöffnet waren
passiert es nichts absolut gar nichts
weil sozialdemokraten grüne linke
kirchenleuten und antifaschisten völlig
friedlich demonstrierten
doch halt eine meinung zwischenfall gab
es vor dem tagungsort der afb wo die
reden der gegendemonstranten stattfinden
sollten kam plötzlich zwei schwarz
gekleidete gestalten hin zu einer hob
die hand zum hitlergruß ein anderer soll
ein t shirt mit hakenkreuz unter der
jacke getragen haben und dass das einige
demonstranten empörte ist
nachvollziehbar und die polizei bekam
die situation aber schnell in den griff
auch wenn sie es nicht gerne hören
wollen nicht linke extremisten haben
dort produziert sondern leute direkt aus
dem umfeld ihres afd parteitages auch
dazu von ihnen kein wort der kritik
wir als linke haben uns dagegen sofort
und entschieden distanziert vom angriff
auf den fdp abgeordneten matthias herr
kollege hat gestanden seine inzwischen
trage
das ist möchte ich habe ihn ja gerade
gesagt wir haben uns klar distanziert
vom angriff auf ihren abgeordneten der
es auch durch überhaupt nichts zu
rechtfertigen die züge aber auch hinzu
es ist auch schwer hinnehmbar wie die
afg diesem vorfall massiv für ihre
politischen zwecke ausschlachtet da war
von einem mordanschlag die rede obwohl
die videoaufnahmen zeigten was
tatsächlich passiert ist
parteichef michael spath von links
terror wohl bis zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
gar nicht klar ist ob die tat überhaupt
politisch motiviert waren und reden wir
doch mal über das verhältnis der afg zum
rechtsstaat da erlaube ich mir doch den
hinweis dass es gegen fast zehn prozent
aller art die abgeordneten bundesweit
strafrechtliche ermittlungen gab oder
gibt
da geht es einfach um körperverletzung
und volksverhetzung und beleidigung
meine damen und herren wir können
wirklich von glück reden dass die
kriminalitätsrate in der bevölkerung
nicht annähernd so hoch ist wie die in
der ard
und reden wir schließlich über menschen
die alltäglich hexe und geweiht
befürchten oder erleben müssen
im jahr 2018 gab es weit über 100
übergriffe auf flüchtlingsunterkünfte
und fast 1500 angriffe auf asyl suchende
außerhalb ihrer unterkünfte und es ist
nicht zuletzt die fdp und ihre
hilfstruppen die dafür mit
verantwortlich sind und das ist leider
auch innenminister seehofer der mit
höchst fragwürdigen äußerungen kräftig
in die hände spielt wer beim thema asyl
ständig eine neue sau durchs dorf treibt
wer die migration zur mutter aller
probleme erklärt der trägt zu einer
weiteren spaltung in unserer
gesellschaft bei und damit muss schluss
sein
kommen wir zum sofa präsident herz statt
hetze
das sollte unser aller motto sein und
deshalb werden wir als linke weiterhin
konsequent jeden gewaltfreien widerstand
gegen die politik der fdp unterstützen
herzlichen dank
der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der linken war dass
andré hahn und die nächste rednerin
kommt von den bündnisgrünen sie ist die
innenpolitische sprecherin ihrer
fraktion irene mihalic
sehr geehrter herr präsident verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen ja die afg hat
mal wieder tief in die zahlen kiste
gegriffen und sich dabei genau das
rausgepickt was ihr am besten in den
kram passt herausgekommen ist ein antrag
ein wildes sammelsurium aus einzelnen
vorgängen jeder menge polemik und
halbwahrheiten das alles hat mit einem
ernsthaftem ringen um die beste
politische lösung nicht das geringste zu
tun
ihnen geht es hier um pure
stimmungsmache dabei dabei bestreitet
niemand dass wir es mit einer viel zu
hohen zahl an politisch motivierten
strafe und gewalttaten zu tun hatten und
damit haben wir uns auch hier im
parlament schon intensiv beschäftigt
wenn ich mal an die debatten zu chemnitz
erinnere oder auch zu dem blog bei
protesten in frankfurt in der letzten
wahlperiode aber ihre darstellung wir
hätten es nahezu ausschließlich mit
einer linksextremistischen bedrohung zu
tun ist völlig absurd und entbehrt jeder
grundlage
allein schon ihre ausgangs feststellung
im antrag die zunehmende gewalt von
linksextremisten ist schlichtweg falsch
wenn sie schon zahlen aus der
polizeilichen kriminalstatistik anführen
dann wäre es gut gewesen wenn sie da mal
etwas genauer hingeschaut hätten gerade
von ihnen herr hess diesem
polizeibeamter hätte ich etwas mehr
sachkenntnis im umgang mit der
polizeilichen kriminalstatistik erwartet
aber ich helfe ihnen gerne weiter der
höhepunkt linksextremer gewalttaten war
das jahr 2015 das schreiben sie ja auch
in ihrem antrag
aber diese zahl von 2246 taten wurde
danach und selbst im jahr 2017 dem jahr
des g20-gipfels in hamburg nicht mehr
annähernd erreicht und wenn man genauer
in die zahlen zu den gewalttaten schaut
dann kommt man zu weiteren
differenzierungen der antrag im übrigen
nicht im entferntesten widerspiegelt so
gibt es vor allem in den jahren 2016 und
2017 jeweils deutlich mehr
körperverletzungen aus dem bereich
politisch motivierte kriminalität rechts
als links 2016 gab es 916
körperverletzungen durch links
motivierte
aber 1393 durch rechts motivierte täter
2017 hatten wir 661 körperverletzungen
links aber 961 rechts und die zahlen für
2018 die grünen mit stand oktober
abgefragt hatten bestätigen diesen trend
da hatten wir nämlich 224
körperverletzungen links aber 557 rechts
sie sehen also dass es nicht besonders
aussagekräftig ist einfach nur die
gesamtzahl gegeneinander aufzurechnen
man muss sich schon wirklich die details
anschauen dann sieht man nämlich auch
dann sieht man nämlich auch dass
landfriedensbruch das hauptsächliche
deliktsfeld von linksextremisten in der
pmk statistik als gewalttat bewertet
wird aber bedrohung und nötigung zum
beispiel nicht aber in diesem
deliktsbereich gibt es ein deutliches
übergewicht von rechts motivierten taten
aber differenzierungen das habe ich
inzwischen verstanden ja sind ja nicht
zu ihr dingen sie haben es ja eher mit
gesamtzahlen und dann habe ich in dem
zusammenhang noch was für sie in ihrem
antrag nennen sie die steigerung im
bereich linksextremismus von 3200 29 auf
6 1393 erfasste straftaten zwischen 2012
und 2017
aber was sie nicht sagen ist dass
rechtsextreme jährlich 20.000 straftaten
verüben und im jahr 2016 waren es sogar
22 1471 ja wo bleibt denn da die
einordnung ganz zu schweigen
ganz zu schweigen
von den politisch motivierten
tötungsdelikten und das schweigen sie
ganz laut und sie wissen auch ganz genau
warum wohl die grotte vorhin
angesprochen jedes opfers eines zuviel
darin sind wir uns hier hoffentlich alle
einig wenn man sich aber die
unterschiedlichen phänomen bereich in
den letzten jahrzehnten anschaut dann
ist es eben hochrelevant liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und in den
offiziellen zahlen sind die zehn
mordopfer des nsu ja noch nicht einmal
aufgeführt ja weil sie eben falsch
eingeordnet worden sind und auch die
neue todesopfer des münchner hamburg
laufs werden bis heute nicht als opfer
eines rechts motivierten täters
eingestuft obwohl ein gutachten dass
sogar die stadt münchen dafür eigens in
auftrag gegeben hat den rechts
motivierten hintergrund glasklar belegt
und allzu oft wird ein
rechtsextremistisches oder ein rechts
motiviertes tatmotiv von den behörden in
irgendeiner art und weise weg definiert
oder irgendwelche verwirrten
einzeltäters zugeschrieben das erleben
wir aktuell zum beispiel wieder beim
attentäter von bottrop
nein meine damen und herren wir müssen
uns auch mit blick in die geschichte
keine sorgen machen dass sich unsere
sicherheitsbehörden irgendwie zu wenig
mit dem linksextremismus aber dafür
vielleicht zu intensiv mit dem
rechtsextremismus befassen
auch der aktuelle
verfassungsschutzbericht weist zb 22
linksextremen gruppierungen aus und
beobachtet dagegen im bereich
rechtsextremismus gerade einmal zehn
also da wird schon sehr deutlich wo sehr
genau hingeschaut wird und viel wie
vielleicht eher nicht als ersparen sie
uns doch bitte ihre dilettantischen oft
gefährlichen halbwissen basierenden
anträge dürfen natürlich niemals
seien es schon alles zu hören
zwischenfrage von sollten ich gestatte
keine zwischenfrage ich komme nämlich
jetzt zum schluss wir würden also wir
dürfen natürlich uns nicht damit
zufrieden geben und müssen wirklich
alles tun um jede extremistische gewalt
in die schranken zu weisen aber das tun
wir selbstverständlich am besten indem
wir auch unsere politischen
entscheidungen oder versuch mit unseren
politischen entscheidungen das
gesellschaftliche klima positiv zu
beeinflussen und dazu gehört eben
zusammenhalt stadt spaltung und toleranz
statt ausgrenzung darum muss es hier wie
in ganz herzlichen dank
irene mihalic war das für die
bündnisgrünen der nächste redner hier in
der debatte um das vorgehen gegen
linksextremismus ist marian wind von der
cdu/csu es mitglied im innenausschuss
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es ist
fast rührend die lieblingsbeschäftigung
der afd
die wiedergabe der kreml propaganda
musste der vermeintlichen sorge um
extremismus weichen
die ard hatte zu diesem topf 1 russland
pavle durch einen diffusen text zum
linksextremismus ersetzt
das ziel ist klar die ard lässt keine
gelegenheit aus um sich als opfer zu
stilisieren
dabei ist sie selbst ein prüfer für den
verfassungsschutz und jens meyer der
selbst ernannte kleine höcker wurde zu
recht aus meiner sicht wegen
rassistischer beleidigung auf ein
schmerzensgeld in höhe von 15.000 euro
verurteilt
ich denke die demokratie und der
rechtsstaat muss nicht nur vor den
linken gewalttätern sondern vor allem
auch vor der afg geschützt werden liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ihr antrag spekuliert darauf bund und
länder würden den linksextremismus
vernachlässigen ganz frisch beispiel
warum das nicht stimmt vor wenigen tagen
wurde durchsuchung des black jungle in
leipzig durchgeführt
dies ist einzig und allein dem
engagierten einsatz der sächsischen
sowie der bundespolizei zu verdanken de
facto wurde damit das objekt geräumt wir
gehen konsequent mit unseren
einsatzkräften gegen linksextremismus
vor ihm geld respekt und anerkennung der
linksextremismus ist eine plage die es
nicht nur verbal zu verurteilen sondern
mit jedem rechtsstaatlichen mitteln zu
bekämpfen gilt ergreift die freiheitlich
demokratische grundordnung und somit
unser gemeinwesen an das bundesamt sind
schutz registriert die ausweitung der
ziele der handlungsfelder des
linksextremismus und auch die zahl der
aktiven im linksextremistischen milieu
das linksextremistische
personenpotenzial ist 2017 und knapp 4
prozent auf insgesamt 19 1500 personen
angewachsen
der zuwachs an gewaltorientierten
linksextremisten betrug dabei 6%
körperverletzung brandstiftung
sachbeschädigung blockaden
landfriedensbruch angriffe auf
polizeibeamte
das sind nur einige der gefährlichen
aktivitäten von links die täter anti
glamour listen antifaschisten
antikapitalisten selbsternannte
antirassisten alle möglichen
splittergruppen trotzkistische sekten
kurz um gewaltbereite antidemokraten und
wir wir müssen regelmäßig vor diesen
gefahren gewarnt werden und dagegen
vorgehen
und deswegen ist ein verdienst des
bundesamtes für verfassungsschutz die
sich hier engagiert dem kampf gegen
links stellen und ist ein verdienst der
cdu csu fraktion die dieses auch ohne
die aphthe in all den jahren immer
wieder thematisiert hat und hier vom
plenum vorgetragen hat
die neuen präsidenten halten bank
wünsche für seine kommende zeit und
seine aufgabe alles gute
wir werden gemeinsam den kampf gegen
extremisten fortsetzen und meine damen
und herren die bundesregierung hat auch
in letzter zeit bereits viel getan um
linksextremistische aktivitäten im
internet und den sozialen medien zu
bekämpfen so wurde unter thomas de
maizière die webseite links unten in die
media bereits im august 2017 verboten
das muss weitergehen wir unterstützen
diesen weg und ich sage auch meine damen
und herren für ein konsequentes vorgehen
gegen linksextremistische webseiten sind
auch die länder mit verantwortlich hier
brauche es eine stärkere noch stärkere
zaubert koordiniert durch den bund um
dieser plage wie gesagt herr zu werden
meine damen und herren die bekämpfung
des linksextremismus ist ein zentrales
anliegen der union
so konnten wir im koalitionsvertrag
unsere genuine forderung nach
nachhaltige absicherung von qualitativ
guten programm zur demokratieförderung
und extremismus prävention sowie den
ausbau unserer erfolgreichen programme
unter anderem gegen diese art von
extremismus verankern
gestatten sie eine zwischenfrage des
kollegen hampel immerzu armin paul
hampel der außenpolitische sprecher der
fdp stimmen sie zu dass sie nach wie vor
die seite in die media links unten und
andere ähnliche seiten mit dem gleichen
inhalt heute nach wie vor in im internet
finden nummer 1 und können sie mir sagen
warum sie seit jahren in der
regierungsverantwortung nicht gegen
diese seite unternommen haben obwohl
dort terror anschläge verurteilt worden
mord aufrufe selbst an ihren
parteifreund in der berliner cdu mord
hetze betrieben worden ist mord aufrufe
erfolgt sind können wir sagen um sie so
viele jahre überhaupt gebraucht haben um
da an staatsanwalt aktiv werden zu
lassen und stehen sie dazu dass die
seiten nach wie vor zu lesen und zu
empfangen im internet sind ihr hampel
wir haben die seite thomas de maizière
hat die seite links unten in die
media.de im letzten jahr verboten
sie ist gelöscht von deutschen schülern
in einem rechtstaat der unser land nun
einmal darstellt können wir nicht auf
die server in anderen ländern zugreifen
wir können dich durch kooperation machen
und da sind wir dabei aber wir können
nicht wie ihnen das vielleicht
vorschwebt die kavallerie schicken oder
einfach einmarschieren und einfach die
server kaputt machen dazu braucht ein
rechtsstaat das mag ihm nicht schmecken
aber so funktioniert ist unserem land
und diesen weg werden wir konsequent
weitergehen den rechtsstaatlichen weg
und dort wo diese dinge im ausland
lagern werden wir entsprechend es tun
sie können ja dann tut ihnen vielleicht
mal fragen ob sie diese kooperation
bereit ist ich glaube viele sehr viele
server die unsere sicherheit bedrohen
stehen in diesem land von dann wäre uns
sehr geholfen vielen dank und damit bin
ich beim punkt ist hilft nicht nur nach
verboten zu lugen nein wir müssen auch
weiterhin die befugnisse der
sicherheitsbehörden stärken
es braucht quellen tks braucht
online-durchsuchung es braucht
verantwortung von internet und mobilfunk
providern um die ermittlungen gegen
links- und rechtsextremisten weiter zu
unterstützen
aber ich sage auch grundsätzlich an uns
alle gerichtet das probate mittel gegen
linx ja gegen jede art von extremismus
ist die stärkung der mitte der
rechtspopulismus der afd hilft ihr nicht
er ist sogar schädlich rechtsgerichtete
parolen eine vermeintlich konservative
head netze waren die linksextremisten
nur an rechts mobilisiert links und
umgekehrt so entsteht extremismus eine
starke mitte hingegen die heute nur die
unions familie darstellt ist einzig und
allein in der lage den links
und rechtsextremismus politisch für
neutralisieren lassen sie uns deshalb
den antrag der fw die ablehnen und
vielmehr die politik der bundesregierung
im bekämpfung des linksextremismus
unterstützen vielen dank maria nennt der
eine zwischenfrage von der afg zuließ
und die nächste rednerin hier in der
debatte ist linda teuteberg sie ist
unter anderem ob frau im innenausschuss
für die fdp-präsident verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen ist richtig und
notwendig linksextremismus und
deutschland zu bekämpfen
es gibt ein problem mit linker gewalt
mit extremistischen strukturen und
organisationen in den sogenannten
alternativen milieus und da ist nichts
aufgebaut die frau schwer sich mal
meinte man muss nur hinsehen
der demokratische rechtsstaat darf auf
keinem auge blind sein nicht auf dem
rechten und auch nicht auf den linken
für für parteien ist dieser anspruch
zwar wünschenswert aber nicht
verpflichtend anders kann man sich nicht
erklären dass die afg einerseits über
linken extremismus sich beschwert aber
gleichzeitig über rechte netzwerke und
extremistische äußerungen in den eigenen
reihen großzügig hinweg sieht allerdings
allerdings würde ich mir wünschen dass
auch auf der linken seite des hauses
genauso auf extremistische entwicklungen
in der linken szene geblickt wird und
man sich nicht dass man sich nicht wie
bei krawallen in hamburg noch als
schutzmacht vor linke gewalttäter stellt
ich erinnere daran bürgerkriegsähnliche
szenen in hamburg wie oft wir hier auf
dem linken auge blind ist der verliert
auch an glaubwürdigkeit wenn er zu recht
rechten extremismus kritisiert es gibt
keine ethische überlegenheit einer
variante des gewaltbereiten extremismus
über die anderen
und wer über die rechtsextremen
entwicklung reden will er darüber
linksextremismus nicht schweigen dazu
muss man sich zum beispiel nur die nähe
der roten hilfe vor allem zur
linkspartei anschauen eine organisation
die linksextreme
vor gericht unterstützt gegen die
auflage dass diese im anschluss ihren
kampf den militanten kampf gegen unsere
republik fortsetzen und nicht mit den
behörden kooperieren
aus gutem grund wird inzwischen darum
auf ein verbot der roten hilfe geprüft
die behörden sind hier eben nicht
einheitlich einige parteipolitische
akteure schonen und es gibt wahrlich
viele dinge die bei unseren sicherheits
und nachrichtendiensten besser
funktionieren könnten und darüber
sprechen wir mit bedauerlicher
regelmäßigkeit im innenausschuss und
manchen untersuchungsausschüssen aber
ein ungleichgewicht in der
aufmerksamkeit gegenüber links oder
rechts extremismus kann ich da nicht
erkennen und das linke und rechte
wechselseitig genau das beklagen
bestätigt er dass dann wenn extremisten
aller farben sich ungerecht behandelt
fühlen manches doch richtig gemacht wird
vor allem diskussion allerdings um
prüfungen oder gar verbote als ultima
ratio des rechtsstaates steht unsere
verantwortung aber mein kollege benjamin
strasser hat es betont dafür wie wir
diskutieren und handeln und zwei
grundsätze sind dabei wichtig gegen
andere die antidemokraten zu sein macht
einen selbst nämlich zum demokraten dazu
gehört mehr und das gewaltmonopol des
staates und die durchsetzung des rechts
sind nicht relativiert ohne wenn und
aber
vielen dank gestatten sie jetzt ist es
eigentlich zu spät eine
zwischenbemerkung von herrn leute vom
bafa vielen dank frau kollegin dass ich
mir merken zu lassen sie haben viel
richtiges über linksextremismus gesagt
aber auch falsches über die afg auf der
seite von verfassungsschutz kann man
nachlesen dass die bewertung unserer
partei auch der umstand mit eingeflossen
ist dass wir uns von klar
extremistischen personen und personen
zusammenschlüssen im distanzieren haben
sie das nicht gewusst oder haben sie das
hier mit absicht weggelassen
die erneute von der harfe jeder von uns
kann hier seine auffassung zum ausdruck
bringen sie ihre ich meine finden und es
war auch eine klare aber sehr knappe
antwort von linda teuteberg die nächst
der nächste redner hier in der debatte
kaum von der cdu csu hans jürgen irmer
hoch verehrter herr präsident meine
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen zur dna der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion und das gilt
für jeden einzelnen abgeordneten in den
hessischen in den held im hessischen
aber auch in allen anderen
bundesdeutschen landtagen gehört es
extremismus gleich welcher art zu
bekämpfen
ob rechtsextremismus linksextremismus
oder islamismus spielt über keine
überhaupt keine rolle extremismus ist
immer schlecht kaffee und deshalb muss
erkämpft werden konsequent meine damen
und herren was in unserer gesellschaft
leider zumindest partiell fehlt ist der
anti totalitäre grundkonsens wonach
gegen extremisten jedwelcher farbe mit
derselben konsequenz und nach denselben
maßstäben vorzugehen ist es ist für die
weitere entwicklung der demokratie ein
gefährliches spiel wenn eine spielart
des extremismus unter artenschutz
gestellt und verharmlost wird lieber
kollege gross bei einer großen
wertschätzung persönliche art wenn sie
sagen der linksextremismus ist im
prinzip weniger gefährlich als der
rechtsextremismus dann ist das schon
eine art relativierung die ich nicht
akzeptieren kann und dem opfer ist es
können egal ob es aus rechtsradikalen
oder linksradikalen motiven heraus
macher attackiert worden ist und im
übrigen kollege haben es ist ja
bezeichnend dass sie zwar zum
rechtsextremismus etwas gesagt haben was
im grunde geworden per se ja auch
richtig ist aber sie haben zum thema
linksextremismus bezeichneter weise
nichts gesagt
und leider ist das thema
linksextremismus ein beredtes
aktuelles thema ich nehme das thema
hambacher forst nehmen das thema g20
hamburg und ich nehme auch das thema ezb
frankfurt und meine damen und herren
wenn sie dort persönlich als familie
betroffen sind bei eine tochter bei
dieser demonstration als polizeibeamte
im einsatz war
dann werden sie manches anders bewerten
als theoretisch von ausstehend
betrachtet dann schauen sie den ganzen
tag fernsehen um zu schauen was passiert
dann möglicherweise mit den
polizeibeamten mit dem eigenen kind was
passiert mit den hilfskräften die
menschen zu hilfe rufen mussten weil sie
von linken störern attackiert worden
sind als feuerwehrkameraden als
hilfsorganisation der weißen
hilfsdienste und anderes mehr
das geht nicht wenn man dann mal schauen
welches waffenarsenal dort zur verfügung
stand dann will ich ihn nur einige
beispiele nennen rohrbomben strom fallen
strommasten umgeweht sprengsätze
molotow-cocktails leuchtraketen
eisenstangen grillen steine gullys
flaschen hakenkrallen böller zerstechen
von reifen lösen von radmuttern
abfackeln von autos
meine damen und herren hat sich jemand
vor diesen hirnlosen einmal gedanken
darüber gemacht dass unter jeder uniform
ein mensch steht ein familienvater eine
mutter die nichts anderes machen als für
die sicherheit und freiheit in diesem
staat einzutreten für unsere freiheit
für unsere sicherheit hat sich jemand
von diesen einfach mal gedanken darüber
gemacht was aus einem schwer verletzten
polizeibeamten wird der in jungen jahren
aus verletzungsgründen den dienst
quittieren muss um mit einer reduzierten
pension auskommen muss hat sich jemand
gedanken darüber gemacht was ist für
eine vierköpfige familie bedeutet wenn
ihr mühsam erarbeitetes auto abgefackelt
wird hat sich jemand gedanken darüber
gemacht was es für einen kleinen laden
besitzer bedeutet wenn seine hütte in
anführungsstriche abgefackelt wird und
erfordert vernichteten existenz steht
ausgerechnet von denen die angeblich den
kleinen mann vertreten die gegen das
großkapital sind die globalisierung der
weltpolitik
meine damen und herren so weit reicht er
verstand dieser leute nicht und wenn ich
im umfeld dieser demonstrationen hier
mal einige aufgetauchte flugblätter
anschaue dann zitiere ich nur vier fünf
sätze aus diesen flugblättern die zeigen
wie enthemmt diese menschen sind auf der
linksradikalen linksextremistischen
seite flugblatt ich zitiere erstens die
bullen sind schweine
zweitens ein dutzend pflanzen könnten
eine demo spitze erfolgreich für
anstürmenden polizisten schützen
drittens völlig unterrepräsentiert sind
derzeit die zwischen schüsse direkt auf
die cops dürften psychologisch wertvoll
sein da dieser erhebliche schmerzen
verursachen
viertens jeder physische angriff auf
staat und kapital und sei es nur das
anspucken eines bullen ist ein kleiner
riss in der demokratischen unterdrückung
skulptur und das letzte besonders gute
effektiv können wir uns für die zukunft
sei der vorstellen um unsere demos zu
schützen genau das ist im übrigen in
frankfurt passiert und dann meine damen
und herren dann kommt eine sed
nachfolger politikerin wie katja kipping
und erklärt am beispiel hamburg wir
hätten dort eine marodierende polizei
meine damen und herren und frau kollegin
wie handelt spricht davon dass die
hamburger polizei zur eskalation
erheblich beigetragen habe ich hätte mir
gewünscht dass sie sich vor die polizei
stellen und ihnen dank und anerkennung
für ihre geleistete arbeit aussprechen
das wäre
der arbeit gewesen und nicht die arbeit
in letzter konsequenz zu reservieren
ich möchte den namen dieses hause
zumindest im namen meiner fraktion allen
polizeibeamten herzlich dank und
anerkennung sagen für das was sie jeden
tag für unsere sicherheit leisten
herzlichen dank hans jürgen irmer war
das von der cdu/csu es geht hier um das
vorgehen gegen linksextremismus der
nächste redner kommt von der spd helge
lind herr präsident liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
sie gaben mir gerade das stichwort mit
ihrer rede
sie sprachen über die situation von
polizeibeamtinnen und polizeibeamten am
24 dezember als ausgerechnet am heiligen
abend rief in meiner stadt wuppertal die
rechtsextremistische partei wie rechte
zu einer demonstration auf und thema der
demonstration war
unverhohlen eine attacke seitens der
rechten gegen die polizei die angeblich
bei demonstrationen der rechte zu scharf
vorgegangen sei und er
demonstrationsrecht unterbunden hätte
wer war denn versammelt bei der
gegendemonstration
ich war da viele mitglieder des mutigen
des linken spektrums aber politiker in
politiker after war nicht gegenwärtig
wenn es ihn so wichtig wäre für die
polizei sich einzusetzen und gegen
extremismus zu kämpfen hätten sie in
erster reihe an diesem tag stehen müssen
erst recht am 24 dezember aber niemand
von ihnen war da niemand deshalb glaube
ich ist es jetzt zeit einmal ganz
nüchtern und aufklärend hierzu wird und
ich nehme drei stichworte das erste
stichwort ist instrumentalisierung dann
wenn die zeit ist auch zulässt statistik
spiel und das dritte ist das klima den
extremismus wird aus einem klima
hervorgebracht zum ersten
instrumentalisierung sie erwähnten
freuen dass einige politiker nur
politiker unter anderen auch meine
kollegin hügel ein aufruf unterzeichnet
hätten gegen die afd
ich muss sagen dass mich das stolz macht
denn das steht in bester tradition der
sozialdemokratischen partei die sich
immer auch unter größten beschwernissen
gegen populismus und gegen extremismus
gewandt hat zum zweiten haben sie das
aber eben begründete es damit dass das
ein aufruf der gegen unsere partei
gerichtet ist und da sind wir beim thema
instrumentalisierung es geht doch gar
nicht um extremismus
es interessiert sie extremismus nur
insofern und auch linksextremismus nur
insofern wenn es gegen sie geht wenn es
gegen sie gerichtet wäre wenn jetzt
gegen andere gerichtet wird würde sie
das thema überhaupt nicht ins nur
interessieren
und gerade deswegen hatten sie eine
zwischenfrage oder zwischenbemerkung
alles kollegen von der steht jetzt nicht
vielleicht ein fortlaufender habe ich
möchte man fluss weiter kommt sehr
geehrte damen und herren geißel der
instrumentalisierung die haben sie gar
nicht erfunden ist dass man das eine mit
dem anhand verrechnet linksextremisten
rechtsextremismus bis 100 mentalist muss
und die afg hat doch immer erklärt sie
wolle sich gegen die altparteien und
gegen solche in ihrem saison
wahrscheinlich umtriebe bin und was sie
machen mich sehr genau zutiefst alt
partei stand in dem sie klassische und
nicht die schönsten spiele der politik
spielen und selber das eine gegen das
andere ausspielen wollen das ist doch
gerade dumm und sie machen damit das
beste für politikverdrossenheit
das wenigste um demokratie in diesem
land zu stärken instrumentalisierung ist
deshalb aber auch das stichwort weil ihr
antrag genau in einem zeitpunkt kommt
wenn bekannt wird dass gegen die afd
ein prüfprozess beim bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz eingeleitet wird und
das als verdachtsfall die junge
alternative die j ahr und auch die
strömung der flügel eingeschätzt wird
eine komische zeitliche incident würde
ich sagen
der aufwand dabei sollten sie eigentlich
den präsidenten des bundesamtes dankbar
sein denn er hat sehr differenziert und
sehr aufklärend in den gefallen getan zu
sagen dass sie als prüf alt sind und
auch nicht verdachtsfall aber es kann
noch schlimmer kommen befürchtet
desweiteren weiß ich auch darauf hin
dass wenn sie von linksextremismus hier
so deutlich sprechen
unlängst die landtagsabgeordneten
bekannt und till schneider bei der
identitäten bewegung in halle
aufgetreten sind und darüber diskutiert
haben die sich denn die afg
verfassungsschutz schützen können das
sind alles seltsame vorgänge wenn man
sich doch so gegen linksextremismus
einsetzen will
und dann finde ich in ihrem antrag auch
noch folgende bemerkung sie fordern
unter drittens eine kommission aus
sicherheitsexperten und linksextremismus
forschern die dafür sorgen soll dass
aufgeklärt wird dass eine so zunehmende
salonfähigkeit ich zitiere von
linksextremismus entgegengewirkt werden
kann und weiter steht da es soll die
bundesregierung maßnahmen zur erhöhten
medialen aufklärung ergreifen und ein
starkes demokratieverständnis wieder
fester in der mitte der gesellschaft
verankern
jetzt frage ich mich wenn wir die selben
forderungen sie betreffend erhoben
hätten was meinen sie was sie für ein
aufruhr veranstaltet und zum zweiten
frage ich was ist das für eine
demokratie bild sie berufen sich dort
darauf dass sie die stimme des volkes
und der bevölkerung sein
und jetzt unterstellen sie derselben
bevölkerung sie sei nicht scharf genug
gegen den linksextremismus und sie
brauchen ein stärkeres
demokratieverständnis das ist
unpatriotisch ich kann das nicht
nachvollziehen
desweiteren und das ist auch im bereich
instrumentalisierung damit komme ich
jetzt zur statistik frage weisen wir
darauf hin in ihren forderungen das wir
ein explodieren linksextremismus hätten
wenn wir aber in die zahlen gehen gibt
dass das spiel gar nicht her sondern ist
es differenziert die zahl der rechten
tag ist sehr hoch in der tat haben sie
recht weil sehr viele davon
propagandadelikte sind die so auf der
linken seite nicht gibt aber und das
erwähnen sie nicht die
zahl der linken tag ist besonders hoch
durch den einmaligen faktor des des
landes riedenburger landfriedensbruches
angesichts des g20 gipfels auch die
tatsache muss man erwähnen
und wenn man das beides ausblendet und
sich zum beispiel körperverletzung
anguckt dann haben wir im jahre 2017
zahlen des bundesamtes für
verfassungsschutz berufen sich auf das
bka 904 körperverletzung
rechtsextremistisch und 499
linksextremistisch das ist zumindest
nicht der ausweis dessen dass der
linksextremismus das wesentlich größere
probleme als der rechtsextremismus sei
deshalb rate ich allen hier beenden wir
diese spiele das gegeneinander
ausspielen von linksextremismus und
rechtsextremismus
es geht auch nicht darum wer aufrufe
gegen welche partei formuliert und dass
man deswegen sich plötzlich gegen
extremismus wird denn extremismus ist
keine linke keine sozialdemokratisch
keine grüne keine liberale keine
christdemokratische keine alternativ
deutsche frage sondern ist eine frage
des selbstverständnisses dieses landes
und dieser demokratie- und wenn es ihn
wirklich um diese demokratie in diesem
land geht dann würden sie nicht
tagtäglich für ein klima sorgen dass
jede form dass jede form von extremismus
fördern in diesem land sondern sie
würden in einem akt des patriotismus für
unser vaterland in ihren eigenen reihen
aufräumen und endlich den grassierenden
rechtsextremismus im umfeld der als de
bekämpfen das wäre die richtige tag
vielen dank
hier gelingt war das für die
sozialdemokraten und einen redner haben
wir noch in der aussprache zu diesem
antrag der fdp fraktion jetzt gibt es
dabei erst noch eine kurzintervention
aus den reihen der eignung kollegen sind
zunächst einmal finde ich es
bemerkenswert dass ein mitglied ihrer
parteien ehemalige polizeibeamte sichern
uns das hier vorne hin steht und die
linksradikale und den linksextremismus
verharmlost die polizisten in diesem
land ihre angehörigen die werden wissen
wie sie das zu bewerten haben und im
übrigen finde ich doch sehr erstaunt
dass die cdu nicht entsprechend
interveniert des windes schon
befremdlich mit feuchten mit welchen
leuten sie hier eine regierungskoalition
machen
sie haben uns unterstellt es die nun zum
uns selbst nein es geht uns nicht um uns
selbst linksterroristen legend in
stetiger regelmäßigkeit deutsche
innenstädte in schutt und asche
betroffen davon sind nicht nur
polizeibeamte sommer sind auch und vor
allem davon betroffen unbeteiligte
bürger beispiele sind vorher schon von
zeitnot cdu genannt wurden und verstehen
sie sind sie bereits zur kenntnis zu
nehmen und auch zu verstehen dass
linksextremismus genau aufgrund dieser
tatsache eine massive gefahr für unsere
demokratie für uns wird das
zusammenleben in unserer gesellschaft
darstellt und dass es eben nicht um uns
selbst geht bei diesem antrag
[Applaus]
es zuhören hilft manchmal der erkenntnis
findung ich habe eben offensichtlich bei
ihnen nicht erfolgreich sechs minuten
plädiert dass wir dieses spiel beenden
linksextremismus böser als
rechtsextremismus all das ist mir völlig
fremd ich habe berge von bedrohung von
rechtsextremistischer seite einige auch
von linksextremistischer das ist so wenn
man innenpolitisch und migrationspolitik
tätig ist aber wenigstens die von links
haben wir noch nicht mit aufhängen und
kopf abschlagen gedroht das ist immerhin
ein zivilisatorischer unterschied ich
selber aber halte dieses gegeneinander
verrechnet für einfach dumm und unklug
und wenn sie wie sie das ja einmal
gemacht haben beim änderungsantrag zum
haushalt die streichung der mittel des
bundesamtes für verfassungsschutz 80
fordern weil sie nicht in gremien
entspreche entsprechend berücksichtigt
worden
dann haben sie da leider gezeigt dass es
ihnen um sie geht mir aber geht es nicht
um mich sondern darum dass dieses land
demokratischer wird und ich würde mich
auch freuen wenn sie mich demnächst
unterstützen würden wenn migrantische
familien oder geflüchtete familien die
ich betreue nicht mehr von anhängern der
idee wären bewegung und anderen
drohanrufe bekommen würden wenn wir uns
da einig sind haben wir einen großen
fortschritt in diesem land und ich lade
sie herzlich ein sich auf diesem weg zu
unterstützen
wieso und jetzt kommen wir
wie bereits angekündigt zum letzten
redner in dieser debatte zumindest
michael kupfer ist das für die cdu csu
fraktion erst mitglied im innenausschuss
weil sie den kolleginnen und kollegen
gekommen dieses zwiegespräche nahtlos
anknüpfen
beide politische extremismus haben nicht
nur eine polizeiliche dimension sondern
leider auch eine gesellschaftliche
verwurzelung und ich muss hinzufügen die
leider auch in diesem parlament und auch
in dieser debatte wieder sichtbar wird
und gerade in dieser gesellschaftlichen
dimension liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
liegt die eigentliche herausforderung
und ich sage mir blick auf den
linksextremismus das toxische am
linksextremismus das toxische an
einzelnen wortmeldungen zum auseinander
zur auseinandersetzung mit diesem
phänomen ist die annahme es gäbe gute
und es gebe schlechte gewalt es gibt
aber liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
keine moralische rechtfertigung für
gewalt im rechtsstaat und es gilt das
gilt für jede form des extremismus sei
er politisch gleich ob links oder
rechtsextremen extremistisch oder auch
religiös motivierte gewalt hat keine
rechtfertigung und sie darf niemals als
mittel der politischen
auseinandersetzung aber auch niemals
mittel geht weder anderen
auseinandersetzung akzeptiert werden
solange dieser satz der die
unverbrüchliche grundlage unserer
gesellschaften und politischen ordnung
bildet bilden soll gesagt werden muss so
lange sind wir in der bekämpfung des
extremismus letztlich nicht erfolgreich
gewesen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
es bleibt die aufgabe von uns und mit
uns meine ich nicht nur die kräfte der
politischen mitte sondern ich meine alle
bürgerinnen und bürgern diese werte in
unserem land zu verteidigen
und die zahlen machen das leider sehr
deutlich dass wir hier noch einen weg zu
gehen haben die anzahl politisch
motivierter gewalttaten ist in den
letzten zehn jahren um annähernd ein
viertel angestiegen
die fallzahlen im linksextremistischen
bereich stiegen im letzten jahrzehnt um
45 prozent an
das ist ein trend der uns zum handeln
zwingt und es darf hier
man kann es nicht oft genug wiederholen
definitiv keine unterscheidung in der
politischen betrachtung der
verschiedenen richtungen des extremismus
geben ich sage es noch mal ganz deutlich
gewalt ist gewalt und an der entwicklung
in den kommenden jahren mit blick auf
das gesagte entschieden entgegenzuwirken
muss deshalb endlich schluss damit sein
gewalt dadurch zu relativieren das auf
ihre motive bezug genommen wird damit
wird gewalt insgesamt verharmlost und
bei manchen äußerungen liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen hat man den eindruck dass
die grenze zwischen angriff und
verteidigung der demokratie von einigen
gehörigen falsch gezogen wird
ich bin zurückhaltend das sage ich ihnen
auch ganz ehrlich mit äußerungen im fall
magna zu viele informationen haben sich
im nachhinein als falsch herausgestellt
aber eines sage ich ihnen auf jeden fall
der satz und ich zitiere das match
zusammengesetzt wurde ist übrigens die
konsequente durchführung von nazis raus
dieser satz ist an dummheit und an
gefährlichkeit nicht zu überbieten und
dass er von einer journalistin gesagt
wurde es ist an zynismus nicht zu
überbieten liebe kolleginnen
und kollegin mit blick sagen jetzt mal
mit blick auf die angriffe gegen
polizisten aber auch mit blick auf
angriffe gegen feuerwehrleute
rettungskräfte werden diejenigen
angreift
die in diesem land tag für tag für das
gemeinwesen für unser aller sache
persönlich den kopf hinhalten
der greift uns alle an und der
unterminiert die stützpfeiler dieser
gesellschaft den wir einen stein auf
einen polizisten wirft der trifft nicht
den start
er trifft einen menschen und er trifft
damit uns alle und deshalb deshalb bin
ich zum schluss alle demokraten sich das
folgende bewusst zu machen
je größer die unterschiede politisch
werden desto stärker muss unser
bewusstsein unser gemeinsames
bewusstsein als demokraten werden die
gemeinsame suche nach dem besten nach
der richtigen lösung in den vordergrund
zu stellen diese absicht liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen sollten wir
auch unseren politischen gegnern niemals
absprechen denn das macht die
unterscheidung zum extremismus und zu
den radikalen kräften aus ich danke
michael kuba war das hier am rednerpult
der letzte debattenbeitrag hier in der
aussprache zu einem antrag der afg
fraktion die fdp fraktion fordert in
diesem antrag dass verstärkt gegen den
linksextremismus vorgegangen werden soll
mit personal und mehr mitteln ja wenn
sie die debatte verfolgt haben
er stellt also in deutschland eine
größere bedrohung da rechts oder links
extremismus da ging es hin und her
allerdings war man sich hier im hohen
haus doch einig das was die anzahl der
politisch motivierten gewalttaten
insgesamt anbelangt die zahl gestiegen
ist und dass gewalt niemals ein mittel
der politischen auseinandersetzung sein
darf darüber hinaus war der konsens
allerdings nicht weil zu der afg antrag
der geht in der es jetzt in die
zuständigen ausschüsse und wird dort
weiter beraten